Speaker 1: Let's do a couple of quick Trump
updates here at the end of the show. Much to the
pleasure of the many and dismay of others, Trump
increasingly having a smaller and smaller role on
this show and in American politics. And I think
that that's a great thing to the extent that he's
horrible and dangerous for American democracy.
Let's start report from Bess Levin of the
Vanity Fair. Trump has been hibernating at home
for almost a month. Yes, Trump has barely left
his house since announcing that he's running for
president in 2024. After a less than rapturous
response to his 2024 campaign announcement, the
ex-president has barely left the grounds of Mar
a Lago. Something is going on here. Something
is going on. Bess Levin writes about Trump's
preparation to announce the bid for office and the
assumption that this would start a two year period
in which he would be feathered the world over.
Everywhere he went, people would spontaneously
break into song and dance, thanking their favorite
president for stepping up to rescue the country.
It is not really happened that way. Trump has not
really been interviewed on any prominent media
since announcing, Hey, I'm a former president
and I'm running again. That's normally would
be pretty big news. And as best Levin writes,
in reality, things didn't entirely pan out that
way. Almost no one in the Republican Party has
come out to support Trump despite threats to
punish Republicans who don't endorse him. Rupert
Murdoch's media empire has spent considerable time
and effort telling people he's a loser. And a
new Yahoo! News YouGov poll released Thursday
has Florida Governor Ron DeSantis beating Trump
by five points. DeSantis hasn't even announced
that he's running. Remember, instead of 24 seven
parades, he was hit with a guilty conviction for
his family business, which a jury said committed
17 different crimes. And Ivanka made clear she
wants nothing to do with Trump's future endeavors.
So the point here is Trump's really not leaving
his house. He's essentially not leaving. The
Washington Post writes Trump Seclusion within
the ornate walls. I call them gaudy. You can call
them ornate. I would call them gaudy walls. Trump
seclusion within the ornate walls of his club
and a series of controversies from dinner with
Antisemites and Nick Fuentes to a social media
post suggesting the termination of constitution
have left him isolated within his own party
as he tries to mount a political comeback.
Herschel Walker's loss on Tuesday is the latest
blow, prompting more Republicans to join the
chorus, faulting him for dragging down the party's
performance in this year's midterms. The former
president presents our biggest risk of losing
for 2024, and conservatives are tired of losing,
said Bob Vander Plaats, head of the Family Leader,
a social conservative group. So bottom line,
Trump's barely leaving his house, and it seems
as though things are not going particularly well.
There's one really funny thing about this now
let's let's talk about the political implications
first. We're two years away. Just under two years
away. I guess we're 23 months away if we want to
make a more accurate count down from the 2024
election. It's too early to say. There is no
momentum and this is going to fail. We we just
don't know that at this point in time. We need
to wait and see if Trump mounts some momentum.
This is far earlier than typically people announce
that they are running. But we've already seen at
least one very good article making the case that
Trump may not even make it to the first Republican
primaries, which I believe. I believe it's Iowa.
I believe a tie won both sides, and that if he
doesn't get momentum going at some point in time,
he may just drop out rather than lose. Now,
someone like Michael Cohen all along argued
Trump wouldn't run Trump's running. But is
he really running in the sense that if you
announce and then you never leave your house
and then you just slowly and quietly go away,
did you really run? Maybe not. That's maybe more
of a semantic discussion. The really funny thing
is that in the run up to the 2020 election,
Trump and MAGA and the Q wing of the party
spent the entire time slamming President Joe
Biden, then candidate Joe Biden for hiding in
his basement and not campaigning. Now, there
was a pandemic at the time, you may recall,
and he still won. And as I've said before, the
really humiliating thing isn't that Biden was
in his basement. It's that if Biden was in his
basement, Trump lost by a lot to a guy who was
in his basement. But now, as the tables seem to
turn, it's Trump who is just hanging out at home
and wishing people getting married at Mar a Lago.
Well, and this sort of thing. I don't really know
how Trump turns this thing around. And what
I mean by that is he can hold rallies, but
there's no rallies for other candidates right now
because there's no other elections. The midterm is
over. So would a random Trump rally in January of
2023. When you're running for something in 2024,
is that going to get attention or is it going
to seem just kind of pathetic? I don't know.
That's one option. Number two, who is going to
go and kiss the ring at Mar a Lago when it's not
clear that Trump actually maintains the political
cachet that people would in the Republican Party
would feel the need to do that. Yes, Kerry Lake
is sucking up to Trump because she wants to be
as VP. Yeah, Marjorie Taylor GREENE is sucking
up to Trump because she wants to be his VP. But
the people. And then you've got people like Mitt
Romney who have said not voting for him no matter
what. But it's very clear that the vast majority
of Republicans at this point are taking a kind of
wait and see approach, which is we're not going
to get behind him until we see how much power he
commands. And at this point, it's not very clear
because he's losing in the polls to people who
haven't even announced, namely Ron DeSantis. So
we're going to follow it. But this is increasingly
a guy who looks like he's out of options and
for now he's staying at home. The one thing
he is doing is he's posting to truth, social
censure. And I want to talk about that next.